القى رئيس الامريكي جوبيدون اليوم كلمه
بمناسبه الذكرى الثانيه لاحداث السادس من
يناير كانون الثاني وقد منح بيضا خلال
الحفل في البيت الابيض 14 من ضباط الشرطه
والعاملين في الكونجرس وسام المواطن
الرئاسي وكان مشرعون امريكيون من الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي قد نظموا فعاليه في
الذكر الثانيه لاقتحام مبنى الكونجرس في
السادس من يناير كانون الثاني عام 2021
وقد شاركت في الفاعليه رئيسه مجلس النواب
السابقه نانسي فلوسي وزعيم الاقليه
الديمقراطيه في المجلس حكيم جفرس
ومعنا الان من البيت الابيض مراسلتنا وجد
وقفي اهلا بك وجد ما ابرز ما تم التاكيد
عليه في الحفل
تم التاكيد عليه حقيقه العباره التي قالها
الرئيس بايدا وشدد عليها هنا في البيت
الابيض اثناء هذا الحفل التكميمي وهي انه
لا مكان للعنف السياسي في الولايات
المتحده ولا مكان لحملات التخويف وترهيب
العاملين في قطاع الانتخابات
الرئيس الجامعه في هذه الفعاليه التكريميه
جمع بين تكريم همم اعضاء من شرطه الكابتل
الاحياء واثنان من الاموات الذين
بجراحه يوم هجوم السادس من يناير على
الكابتل وجمع بين ذلك وبين ايضا تكريم
الموظفون في الانتخابات الذين رفضوا
الخطوع لما وصفه بايدن بحملات الترهيب
والتخويف وتهديدهم هم وعائلاتهم بعكسي
نتائج
غابات عام 2020 عدد منهم دعاهم البيت
الابيض جاؤوا من ولايات عده وهي الولايات
التي حسمت النتيجه الانتخابيه والتي بحسب
الرئيس بايدن كانوا يتعرضون لتهديدات
وضغوط من اجل تغيير نتائج الانتخابات في
دوائرم الانتخابيه هؤلاء تم تكريمهم اليوم
طبعا الرئيس قال ان الهجوم على الكعبه على
رمز الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده تم
بسبب سلسله من الاكاذيب لم ياتي على ذكر
الرئيس السابق ترامب محمد ولكن كلنا نعلم
بان من نفذ الهجوم على مبنى الكابتل همم
في السادس من يناير كانوا من انصار الرئيس
ترامب انا ذاك عندما جاء الى هنا الى
البيت الابيض خاطبهم وحذفهم على الذهاب
الى الكونغرس في يوم المصادقه على النتائج
الانتخابيه من قبل اعضاء الكونجرس
من البيت الابيض